here are some of the most popular and
affordable ways for an artist to make
money these days first
sell your art online
this is the most obvious and easily
realized way
it doesn't require having your own store
or a large audience
thanks to the internet you can sell your
art online through different platforms
like sd and fine art america
second
sell paintings at art exhibitions
this is the most prestigious way
to be honest not every artist can boast
about it
but if you're lucky enough to have an
agent you can probably make an entire
year's budget by selling a few paintings
third
creating and launching online drawing
courses
it requires a lot of resources at the
beginning of the launch
you need good filming equipment and
light
in addition to this you also need to
know how to shoot and process video
creating an online course and releasing
it is one thing but selling it is a more
complicated task
the same principle works here as with
paintings
if you have a large audience and
knowledge of marketing and sales then
with some effort you can cope with this
task
if not you can place your online courses
on already promoted and popular
platforms such as udemy or skillshare
fourth
make money as a freelance illustrator
you can register on a freelance website
and publish your portfolio and then
maybe you will be noticed by customers
and will be offered some interesting
projects
sites like upwork and freelancer are
popular freelancer platforms that have
broad categories and service listings
you can provide them your service and
get paid for that
lastly
release an educational book on drawing
you can compile a simple guide on how to
draw or drawing techniques
then you can make an electronic version
that can be downloaded for a certain
amount of money
the best part
your book doesn't have to be about
techniques and theory either
you can put together an art book with
your best illustrations or paintings
many self-published ebook authors turn
to amazon to get their books sold for
kindle
you can also go the classic route find a
publisher and publish the book together
if you can do it well you can earn a lot
thank you for watching and
subscribe for more